-Bobby Moynihan right here,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to talk about this.
-Oh, yeah.
-Did you get to talk to Margot?
I know Margot hosted the show
"SNL," when you were
a cast member.
-Yeah, she was wonderful
when she came.
I had written a sketch called
"The Librarian"
that I tried to get on like
many, many times.
And she came and she knocked it
out of the park.
And she nailed it.
Yeah.
-What do you remember about
"Saturday Night Live"?
Were you nervous when you first
got on the show?
-No, I was fine.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow! No story here.
You were telling me backstage,
was it the week before
or the night before,
you just got on
"Saturday Night Live."
Wasn't announced.
-Yeah, yeah, the night before
my first Monday.
So it was the Sunday night
before I'm supposed to go in.
My life's dream
has now come true.
I couldn't believe it.
And I went to
Upright Citizens Brigade,
which they had
a show there called Asssscat,
and we would perform there.
And I went, and I was like,
"Oh, my gosh!"
Like, "I'm gonna start 'SNL'
tomorrow.
This is amazing."
And I was in my own head.
And five minutes
before the show started,
Robin Williams walks in.
And he's just --
they're just like,
"Hey, do you mind if Robin
performs with you?"
And I was like, "What?!"
And Robin Williams showed up
and did a show with us.
And it was, like,
the second-best thing
in the world
that could have happened.
-Yeah, "Saturday Night Live."
You're like, "Wait.
What is going on with my life?"
-Exactly.
And then, after the show,
Robin grabbed me
by the shoulders and was like,
"I have an idea.
Give me your clothes.
I'm gonna go into work
for you tomorrow.
You just got
'Saturday Night Live.'
Wouldn't it be hilarious
if I went into work for you."
And I remember
instantly thinking,
"Oh, no.
This is a terrible idea."
[ Laughter ]
I do not want my first day
at "SNL" to have Lorne Michaels
see Robin Williams walk in
in a Bart Simpson T-shirt.
I was like, "No, this is --"
Don't do bits the first day
at work.
-And I'm like, "How do you
tell Robin Williams no?
And he was 100% serious.
And then, I was terrified.
He gave me his number.
And I was like, "Oh, no.
This is gonna happen."
And he never called,
and I was really happy.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, he probably thought
about you, said, "Oh, I'm gonna
let the kid
become a star first."
-Yeah, I think he thought
it was a fun idea,
and maybe he saw the complete
and total panic in my face.
-Yeah. I want to talk about
this, by the way.
Look at this.
"Not All Sheep are Boring!"
Congratulations, buddy.
You wrote this book.
What inspired you to write this?
-I have a daughter,
5-year-old daughter,
and a lot of bedtime reading
and started talking about
counting sheep.
And I was like,
"Why do people do that?
Why do we count sheep,
specifically, to fall asleep?
Are they all boring?"
And I wanted to get
to the bottom of it.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
You really solved the case.
-Yeah, I tried to.
Turns out they're boring,
a little boring sometimes.
-Yeah.
There's a lot of --
What do you call it?
-Dedication. Yeah.
If a publisher gives you
the chance
to have a thank-you section
in a book,
you use it
to its full potential.
So, as you can see --
-Yeah, you thanked
a lot of people here.
-Yeah, many.
And then there's also a website
at the bottom that continues
people who I forgot to thank
in the sheep dedication.
So you can go to that website.
There's a lot more on there.
[ Laughs]
-I mean, you thank --
-I thank everybody
from my high school buddies,
my high school teachers.
-Keanu Reeves?
What has he done for you?
-For me personally?
-For this book.
-I mean, entertained me
my entire life.
For this book?
Nothing.
[ Laughter ]
-He has nothing to do
with this book, Keanu Reeves?
-Keanu Reeves probably
doesn't know this book exists,
and I'm fine with that
because he's a nice man
who treats people well,
and I say, "Thank you, Keanu."
-Oh, there you go.
I love that.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He's a really good guy.
[ Both laugh ]
-You thank George Lucas.
Do you know him?
-Not personally, no.
-There you go, okay.
[ Laughter ]
The beverage peach Snapple.
-Yes, thank you very much.
I love it.
It's a very delicious drink.
-I love you put
"the beverage peach."
Is there another peach Snapple?
-Oh, just in case you thought
it was the person.
[ Laughter ]
-You thanked the beverage.
-Mr. Peach Snapple.
-Mr. Peach Snapple, yeah.
And so if you go to
peoplewhodidnotfit
inthededication
ofnotallsheepareboring...
-No, it's very easy to read,
Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a great --
how'd you get that website?
It wasn't taken?
-It wasn't taken!
Can you believe it?
[ Laughter ]
-Usually an author, you know,
you'll have the photo
of the author,
you know, in the book.
The photo you chose is this.
-Yes.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-That is --
-That is the boy I hired
to write the book.
-No, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
He's very talented.
-Yes.
-He wrote this for you.
-Yeah, he's very good.
He's 5.
He's an author now.
-His name is Peach Snapple.
-Peach Snapple.
-Pete Schnapple.
Yeah, I can see the confusion.
-Yes.
-But it looks
like you as a child.
-I mean, nothing has changed.
-You look the same, buddy.
Come on.
Well, this guy --
[ Laughter ]
Stop making that face.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This boy would be
very proud of this man.
He really would.
Congratulations, Bobby Moynihan.
Thank you for
coming on the show.
-Thank you so much, man.
It's such a pleasure, as always.
-"Not All Sheep are Boring!"
is out tomorrow.